83 % de nos concitoyens sont pour le
droit pour chaque enfant d'avoir un père
83% dans les garder sous votre article
il interdit va interdire les enfants à
jamais d'avoir un père c'est ça très
clairement la la proclamation que vous
faites vous voyez vous au niveau des
femmes de nouveaux droits
sachez simplement que vous allez
interdire à des enfants à naître jamais
avoir un père et ça il ya une large
majorité de français qui compte avec
l'adoption de l'amendement touraine vous
me vous venez délibérément de mettre le
pied dans la porte de la légalisation de
la gpa en france pratiquent le 16-7 du
code civil
il ne suffit pas mes chers collègues de
dire la gpa non nous ne voulons pas ça
n'est pas éthique mais c'est interdit
c'est dans le coaching pas de problème
regardez ce que vous venez de voter
regardez ce que vous venez de voter la
gpa defacto est désormais autorisée dans
notre pays
defacto c'est ce qui va se passer mais
les français sont émus car ils sentent
comme nous que ce président leur
président est peut-être le dernier de
cette trempe
un homme simple humble fraternelle droit
et patriote qui a su nouer une relation
charnelle avec notre pays
nous l'aimions et nous pensons avec
émotion à madame chirac à sa fille
claude et à martin son petit fils le
vide que les français ressentent notre
famille politique
la sienne le mesure avec une infinie
tristesse et une envie farouche d'être
digne d'être fidèle à ses combats à ses
valeurs à sa mémoire et à son héritage
merci monsieur le président
adieu veaux vaches cochons couvées vous
abandonné en rase campagne tous les
objectifs de finances publiques que vous
aviez vous même fixé le budget 2020 et
celui du moindre effort en trois ans la
dette publique a augmenté de 190
milliards d'euros les dépenses publiques
ont augmenté de 78 milliards d'euros et
le déficit de l'état lui-même de 25
milliards d'euros en trois ans vous êtes
passés d'une timide politique de l'offre
plutôt favorable aux entreprises à
l'activité économique et donc à
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat par
les revenus à une politique de la
demande qui repose sur des baisses
d'impôts et des hausses de transferts
sociaux le tout abondamment financé par
la dette
vous privilégiez le court terme aux
impératifs de long terme
vous misez tout sur les bonnes nouvelles
extérieur au lieu de réaliser des écoles
par ailleurs vous dites baisser
massivement les impôts l'année prochaine
mais les entreprises paieront 16
milliards d'euros en plus d'impôts sur
les sociétés et les ménages 3 milliards
d'euros en plus d'impôt sur le revenu
les bonnes nouvelles se transforme en
mauvaise nouvelle car vous reprenez en
partie d'une main ce que vous avez donné
de l'autre
le groupe intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat le giec à 12 24
septembre les conclusions d'un nouveau
rapport sur les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique sur les océans
et la cryosphère ses leçons sont celles
ci sont plus qu'à l'artiste puisque le
niveau des mers pourrait monter jusqu'à
1 m 10 d'ici 2100 avec des conséquences
sur la population mondiale 680 millions
de personnes vivent en zones côtières
n'est-il pas temps de faire davantage
pour répondre à ce défi majeur
vous avez annoncé il y a un an ici même
le retour à l'équilibré du budget de la
sécurité sociale en 2019
mais il n'en est rien le difficile cette
année que l'année prochaine et cédera 5
milliards d'euros si la croissance plus
faible que prévu explique en partie la
situation
la non compensation des mesures
d'urgence par le budget de l'état est un
choix votre choix politique qui n'est
pas sans conséquence alors que les
attentes sont immenses dans les hôpitaux
au vous demandez encore plus d'économies
et des fois au d'établissement mais ma
question s'adresse à monsieur au camp
me sert pour les retraites monsieur le
haut commissaire vous avez mis je
voulais déjà dit le monde des libéraux
en colère pour la première fois dans
l'histoire sociale de notre pays ces
professionnels libéraux dénoncent le
projet qui est un projet de captation de
leur régime autonome de retrait jeudi 26
septembre dernier en milieu de nuit un
énorme incendie s'est déclaré dans une
usine pétrochimique de la ville de rouen
les sapeurs pompiers de seine-maritime
renforcés par leurs collègues des
départements limitrophes ont réagit
aussitôt et avec efficacité pour
contenir puis éteindre la cet incendie
alors que le gouvernement fait la sourde
oreille aux revendications des pompiers
qui sont en grève depuis plus de trois
mois les députés les républicains
veulent saluer la promptitude et
l'efficacité de nos soldats du feu
depuis jeudi matin un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été prises ou qui n'ont
pas été prises
interroge et inquiète les populations de
normandie et de picardie
monsieur le ministre vous convenez que
notre système de secours et d'urgence
est à bout de souffle
elle et ses sites une profonde réforme
mais c'est à l'état d'assurer la
sécurité de serviteurs car les soldats
du feu n'en peuvent plus monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez pas répondu non
plus au mouvement de grève qui perdure
depuis le mois de juin dernier
et vous n'avez pas endiguer la crise des
vocations qui frappe cette profession
monsieur le ministre la république et la
représentante nationale exige des
réponses concrètes
[Musique]